non on va jouer tout de suite au ni oui
ni non
ni oui ni non mais une tarte c'est une
minute attention si tu perds j'imagine
relève sa magie enfin comment ça va ça
va bien pas mal sportif on dirait un bon
champ cif ça m'arrive ça c'est du sport
ce matin a déjà un petit peu pas en quoi
ce matin et le soir peut-être le sanwi
là bas parce que tu es jeune batteur
ça m'a regardé exact ces tout jeunes
alors très jeune tapis par région
parisienne pas loin marié pas encore
amoureux peut-être
j'aimerais bien elle n'est pas là non
quel est votre plat favori mon plat
favori c'est les holmes est déjà à 20
heures c'est bien vous avez joué là je
crois que j'aime bien je vous dis
attendez quand je pense pas c'est quand
je parle
oui
[Musique]
soir usa bat grand cravate de couleur
sur une crotte les jours c'est votre
style
un vrai bon rang 6 à 60 j'aime pas
jamais serein certains certes un certain
jésus comme en voiture
à votre avis les risques pour les
conduire à la ribère détendez vous vous
vous lancez rien du jeu c'est pas assez
fort assez pour passer faut gérer ça va
très bien valerie jarrett avait failli
écrire lingots le dirige aussi j'avais
cima fréquemment tous les soirs au
presse parce que le tous les soirs
presque mais pas tout le temps quand
même pas tout le temps plutôt les scènes
avec des dauphins
tout cela nourrit certains franchement
oui non
oui
j'adore danser les anciens turc
habertürk du jazz le jazz aussi le hip
hop et deviendra le reggaeton touareg et
hop c'est bien ça je pense très bien
vague automne vous ne fera pas avec moi
voulons que jamais sur un détendez-vous
cela je le dis jamais vous avez la bande
depuis longtemps si moi ce que je peux
m'approcher de bouffer fatto cacherai
pas je sais pas trop près là pas du tout
varié
j'adore quand vous êtes près de moi
visite chez nous pas un loup non mais tu
commençais droite étaient jetés jeunes
débuté au tennis tu te souviens pas du
tout je devais succès avec quelqu'un
allait faire date et les plus tard
effectivement tenir mon bureau et il m'a
dit ça oui
[Applaudissements]
jean pierre des corps qui seraient tous
non personne n'à d'aller à bercy long
terme
[Musique]